this morning we bring you the story of a
North Carolina man inspired by his own
mother's health struggle he's giving
cancer patients a better shot at
fighting the disease simply by giving
them a ride
mark Strassmann shows us the power of
lending a hand
your words keep us going why can't you
keep going I'm doing for cancer patients
often greet Zack bolster like an
oncologist with all the answers
it's crazy put a face to a voice and to
see the impact we're having directly
he's not a doctor but a guy in Charlotte
who was given hundreds of patients a
lift cancer can be scary and feel
uncontrollable and we want to take this
one piece of the process transportation
and make it simple in November of 2016
bolsters mother Gloria needed treatment
for Stage four pancreatic cancer he quit
his job on Wall Street and moved to
Charlotte to drive her to appointments
bolster noticed other patients often
elderly or low-income had no reliable
ride frankly was infuriating to see
people struggle just to get to
life-saving treatment and we just wanted
to do something about it there was a gap
in the care absolutely bolsters mother
died weeks after learning she had cancer
I am great thank you
in March of last year he launched the
nonprofit chemo cars the group
coordinates with uber and lyft to drive
cancer patients and it's free paid for
by donations somebody won't take me and
somebody gonna pick me up
Patricia Curie calls chemo cars a lot
she has stage three breast cancer and no
other ride to treats you don't know what
plan I was trying to come up with but
thank all the sex plan QT Jo she's 80
year old father Shree has colon cancer
and uses chemo cars
her parents are skittish drivers and she
lives in Dallas a thousand miles away if
this was that one thing that okay that's
one thing off of our plate are you good
at keeping hydration going at Novant
Health Pam Gwaltney is an oncology nurse
I don't have to call it their family
have their son or daughter leave work to
take him for treatment possible
not be able to keep their job every ride
honors the memory of bolsters mother
when patients call chemo cars they're
dialing her old cell phone number
why so passionate about it it just makes
me feel good to make a difference it was
unfair to see that not everyone has the
same shot at beating cancer let's keep
it alive whatever it takes when these
people express their gratitude for the
help you didn't find out in Wall Street
it's powerful what would your mom say
about this she'd be proud of what we're
doing for CBS this morning
mark Strassmann Charlotte Zack poster is
using his mom's cell phone number that's
when this one cheek on sort of a full
circle moment it is a brilliant idea I
do know even from people I know that's
one of the hardest things getting a ride
when you're sick and it's great uber and
lyft working doing this together even
though they're competing and it means so
much the the gratitude you feel when
that one thing is taken care of